Today, clearly,
I am a noble gas.
Thanks to-- it was
actually the TAs' idea.
And I was like, of course,
that sounds awesome.
So I hope you guys have
a fantastic Halloween.
Obviously, what you want
to do is any kind of trick
or treating or partying,
you know the drill,
you bring your periodic
table, because you never know.
And that's what happened--
so on Sunday right before
the exam, I got this.
And so this is
Charles and Raymond.
And they're saying we
wanted to celebrate the Sox
victory in Boston, but because
the midterm was the next day,
we brought along our
periodic table to study.
There were so many
people moving around it
felt like we were in
a sea of electrons.
And of course, the
only thing that
could have improved
on that was actually
like a little dance video.
But that will probably come.
I'm sure there on that next.
But you see, they brought it
not just to study for the exam,
because they didn't know if
it was going to be important
or not at the rally.
You never know.
So make sure you have your
periodic table with you.
Now, OK, oh, yeah, they
mentioned the exam.
So speaking of the exam.
Here are the results.
And you can see that there is
a pretty wide distribution.
You can also see
the averages is 77.
And just to remind you--
that's about here--
just to remind you, these
marks, 85, that's the A range.
This is the B range.
So the average was in the
solid B range territory.
And so it goes.
The standard deviation was 12.
Now I could tell-- you
know, the exam 1,
the topics of exam 1 many
of you had already seen.
And I think in this
exam, some of you had not
seen some of these
topics, especially
like the
crystallography, but also
even the molecular orbitals,
the band structure.
And I could tell that, you know,
some people had to work harder,
maybe a little bit stressed,
and I could sense, some of that.
But when I get
stressed what I do
is I need to kind of
de-stress somehow.
And sometimes some
people listen to music,
some of the other things.
I always like comedy
as a way of relaxing.
And so what I do
is I'll Google like
for articles about Harvard.
And so I found this one.
This is actually an
article in The Crimson
from a few years ago.
And the most common
grade at Harvard
is actually an A, a solid
A, the most common grade.
Suspicion that the college
employs a softer grading
standard than many of
its peer institutions.
You think?
I mean, if everyone's
getting an A, you think?
So what I wanted to point
out is there's a difference.
And it's not just about
your privileged, therefore,
you deserve an A, whereas
we know that that actually
takes work.
That's not the point
I want to make.
The point I want to make
is that we know also
what to do when we miss things.
We know what to do when
we don't get things right.
That's when you do the work.
So wherever you
are on this curve,
go back and figure
out what didn't work.
What did you miss?
Figure that out, because
that's where you learn.
Thomas Edison who said,
I never failed, I just
did 10,000 experiments
that didn't work.
You've got to get through that.
You've got to know that
it takes hard work.
And that's the thing
that we know here.
That's the difference.
So please make sure you
do that with exam 2.
We are all here to help
you continue learning.
I'm a noble gas.
And speaking of continuing
to learn, where were we?
X-rays.
On Friday, we had sort of
some other things going on.
But I also was trying to
teach you guys about X-rays.
And what we did is we learned
how they're generated.
Remember that?
The Roentgen experiments.
And so I want to pick up
here with the kinds of X-rays
that we have.
There are two kinds of X-rays.
And we learned about
those on Friday.
And I want to just
remind you about those.
And I also want to show you
a video to kind of recapture
what they are.
The first kind of
X-ray, remember,
we plotted this as intensity.
And I'm not going to
draw the cathode ray
tube again and the experiment
that Roentgen did and all that.
But I'm going to just jump
to the two kinds of x-rays
that you get.
And so if you plot
the wavelength
of the X-ray versus the
intensity of the X-ray,
then one kind is
the Bremsstrahlung,
which comes from that that
electron getting slowed down.
And if it slows down,
it emits radiation
in a continuous spectrum.
And remember, we
sort of drew these.
And this would be like the
incident electron energy.
Let's say incident
energy of the electron.
Maybe like that's, OK, I
don't know, like 10 keV.
And then up here the incident
energy of the electron
was you know something
like maybe 30 keV.
And so you see that as you
hit that anode, remember what
Roentgen did, he took
a cathode ray tube
and he upped the voltage.
So he really cranked
up the voltage.
So those electrons
coming off the cathode
are going really fast.
And then what he did is he put
a piece of metal in their way.
And what happened is those
really high energy electrons,
they see those metal
atoms and sometimes they
get inside the electron
cloud and they turn.
And that's when they give off
this continuous radiation.
But we also know that
there is a limit here.
Remember that?
We talked about that?
And that this limit is
set by this maximum.
It's just the maximum
amount of energy
that you could get
out of a photon being
emitted this way would be
equal to the incoming electron.
The incoming electron
transferred all of its energy
to the photon.
So that's why
there is a maximum.
And it's also why it increases--
remember, shorter wavelength,
higher energy--
so it increases as you
increase the energy
of the instant an electron.
That is Bremsstrahlung.
Let's watch a video,
because this is actually
a very nicely done video that
captures it with animation.
So OK, here's your CRT.
Now here they come.
Those are those electrons.
And that voltage is high.
So they're coming out.
Look at them coming
out really fast.
Lots of kinetic energy.
And then they go.
And then this is
what Roentgen did.
He put a little piece
of metal in there.
So now those electrons
are hitting the metal.
So those are the two things
that he did differently.
Remember, the room lit up even
when all the lights were off.
There they are.
Nice.
Good electrons.
Oh, and here they go.
And there's a metal atom.
And oh look at that.
Now what are these?
Those are x-rays coming off.
Those are the electrons
hitting the metal.
And here's the metal atom.
And as the electron
comes in, remember
it sees the charge
of the nucleus.
And it gets deflected.
And that deflection
loses energy.
And that loss of energy
goes into a photon.
Now, because these electrons
have such high energy
to start with, the energies
of the photons are very high.
They're x-rays.
And so here's the wavelength.
And you can see that--
well, it's sort of a little
hard to see this blue range.
But see higher energy,
shorter wavelength.
Lower energy, longer wavelength.
Very nice.
So that's the animation
of Bremsstrahlung.
OK.
Good.
Now the thing is
what we also learned
is that there is
another type of X-ray.
There's another type of X-ray.
And in fact, if you crank
this up high enough,
you can get that other type.
So now, we go higher.
Oh, we didn't see it here.
It just looks like
that and that and that.
And then all of a sudden we go
up to 40 keV and we see this.
Why?
What happened here?
And what happened here is a
totally different mechanism
for generating X-rays.
And that was the second type
that we talked about on Friday.
Those are called characteristic.
And the reason is that--
remember, we have these levels,
which now that we are
talking about X-rays,
we give them
letters, K, L, M, N.
But it's just the
quantum numbers.
n equals 1.
n equals 2.
n equals 3.
n equals 4.
And what we said is that
the weight characteristic
X-rays are labeled is
that if an electron is
excited from this lower level,
if an electron is knocked out
of here, then there's a place
for an electron from here
to go down.
Maybe the electron is excited.
Maybe the electron
is kicked out.
And then something
here can come down.
And when that happens, just
like in the Bohr model,
you get radiation.
But now, unlike
hydrogen 13.6 electrons,
these are keV of energy.
These are very high energies.
Why?
Because it's the one S electron.
And we know that once you
get down to those metals,
those one s electrons,
you go further
down the periodic table,
1s electrons are seriously
tightly bound.
And those levels have
a difference down there
that is pretty high in energy.
It's X-ray high in energy.
That's the point.
So now, when that
cascade happens,
we call that a k alpha.
And if it were to
have come from here,
it would be called a k beta.
And those are transitions, that
unlike this continuous energy,
those transitions only happen
at very specific energies,
delta energies.
The change in
energy from L to K--
or for K beta it would
be going from M to K.
It's k alpha, k beta.
We use the k because that's the
final place the electron goes
when it decays down.
So if I just showed
you these, well, that
would be like k alpha, and
that would be like k beta
because you know the k beta
is going to be a higher energy
photon because it came
up from a higher level.
Well, you would also have
on here some other peaks.
You would have the L peaks.
So you'd have like
L alpha, L beta.
So as you crank the
energy up, then you
can knock out those
core electrons
and these cascades happen and
you get these discrete peaks.
Notice, they will only come
when you have enough energy
in that incident electron
to knock this electron out
from the core.
So that's why they
don't appear until you
get to a certain
incident electron energy.
They don't appear until you
get to that certain energy.
And so we have a video on that,
which also I will narrate.
Is this it?
There we go.
So there it is.
It's a metal atom.
I don't know which one.
OK, there's the
incident electron.
You fired it.
And look at that.
It knocked out a
core 1s electron,
because it had enough
energy, very high energy.
That's what Roentgen
did, cranked up
the voltage, higher keV.
And there it is.
A cascade down and
an X-ray comes out.
You see that?
Is that all?
Oh, yeah, and then
it's going to draw--
because of those, you get
these characteristic peaks.
Now, we call them
characteristic,
because now you see why.
So unlike the
continuous radiation,
these peaks depend on
the atom, because they
depend on the energy
levels of the atom.
And so that's why like
if you looked this up,
you say, well, OK, let's look
at the k alpha radiation.
Let's look at the
k alpha peaks that
come out of different atoms.
They're going to be different.
So you have very
sharp lines of x-rays
at very specific energies.
For copper, it's 8 keV.
For molybdenum it's 17.5.
Silver tungsten, it changes.
And you can see that it goes
up, as that 1s electron is
lower and lower energy because
I'm adding all these protons.
So it all makes sense from
the concepts we've learned.
Oh but see, now
that's really useful.
That is really useful,
because now I've
got a way to have
a source of X-rays
that is super well defined.
It's super clear.
It's always this--
that's so cool.
As long as I have the same
metal, it's always the same.
I can increase or decrease--
well, I can't go
below the threshold.
But I can't go above it.
And that peak is
characteristic of the metal.
So it doesn't change.
That's really useful because
I've got now a flashlight.
I've got an X-ray
flashlight where
the energy that I'm
sending out is always
exactly what I know it to be.
I can predict what it is.
And it always will be that
depending on which medal
I put in there.
So that's a useful thing.
Why is that useful?
Well, that gets to the topic
that is the topic of today
and of Friday, which is what
are we doing with these X-rays?
Well, first, we're
generating them.
So that's what we've
talked about so far.
But now, we're going
to actually use
them to determine the
crystal that we have.
We're going to
actually use them.
We're going to use
that flashlight.
And so you can see why
this would be useful,
because this is the range--
we've showed this before--
of X-rays.
So they have these
energies of keV.
And they have wavelengths
right around a few Angstrom.
That is a little less than an
Angstrom, maybe 2 Angstroms.
See where those wavelengths are?
Well, those are atomic spacings.
Those are like distances
between layers.
And so if we could
shine these on a crystal
and somehow figure out what
it is with that light--
oh, there's a way
we can do that.
It's called diffraction.
Because what happens is--
and we know this
from many fields.
You can think about this just
as a water wave, any way.
If the wavelength is similar
in size to the features,
then you get constructive
and destructive interference
as a result of the
interaction between the wave
and the features.
So that's called diffraction.
And you can see it here with
this very simple picture
of say a water-- this
could be like a water
wave, a sound wave.
And there it is.
And it's interfering
both constructively
and destructively
along these lines.
You can do this test yourself.
You can take--
I highly recommend this--
take a laser pointer.
Now if I just had
a piece of metal--
I don't have a piece
of metal, but if I did,
then I would shine it on it.
And what you'd see is
that the dot would just
reflect off the piece of metal.
So I just would
get the dot back.
But now I've got
this thing here.
Many of you may
not know what this.
This is called a CD.
But it turns out that a
CD has features in it.
It's got trenches that are like
a little less than a micron
apart, 100 nanometers.
And this is 500 nanometer light.
So you would expect
there to be diffraction.
You would expect there to be
constructive and destructive
interference.
And when I bounce it off
of this, look at that.
There it is.
This never gets old.
I'm not getting just
one reflection here.
I'm getting a whole scatter of
them that have constructively
interfered, because of
the feature sizes being
the same as the wavelength.
But now, I want to
do that with X-rays.
And I want to do
it onto crystals.
So how do we do that?
So let's think about that.
And we're going to think
about it in terms of what
the Bragg father-son pair, who
won the Nobel Prize and are
on a stamp.
That's what you get when you
win a Nobel Prize I guess.
And what they did is they
figured out how to do this.
So let's go through that just so
we understand it conceptually.
So I'm going to say that
I have a set of atoms.
Now, I'm not going to
worry about what they are.
But I'm just going to say that
there's some plane of atoms
here.
And there's another plane
of atoms beneath that.
So there is another one
and so on and so on.
And now, these would
be Miller planes.
These would be Miller
planes in the crystal.
And let's just assume
they're very, very simple,
this plane and that plane.
And now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to have some x-rays.
I'm going to have some
light shining on this.
And it's going to be incident.
And it's going to be reflected.
But see, I'm going to
have another wave here.
OK, let's see if I can
get through this drawing,
sort of, almost, kind of.
Now, here's the deal,
these are waves.
So if I want to
draw this as a wave,
I might draw it like that.
And if these waves are
constructively interfering,
let's just complete that, then
this wave would look like that.
If they're in phase, then that's
what they would look like.
Now, this one's getting
reflected off the surface.
So I'm going to do
that reflection here.
And if I wanted to come
back off of the surface,
and this one got
through the first layer,
this didn't get reflected.
It's going down.
And if I want it
to come back up,
then this one must also look
like that to be in phase.
They must be in
phases they come out,
or else they're not going
to interfere constructively.
You see that?
So those are my X-rays.
They're waves.
They're just waves.
Oh, but this is
the whole secret,
because if this angle here is
theta, then what that means
is that this angle is theta.
And if that's true,
then this distance
is d sine theta,
where this is d.
That's just some
simple geometry.
So what you know then
is, OK, now we're
getting somewhere, because
you know if I had a wave,
this is one wavelength.
So if I had a wave come
in like this and one
of them is going to get
reflected off of this lower
surface and the other one
got reflected on this,
but I don't want them
to interfere in any way
but constructively, that's what
Bragg said, Bragg and Bragg.
That's what they said.
Then the only way
for that to happen
is if this distance
plus that distance--
so d sine theta
plus d sine theta
is equal to some multiple
of the wavelength.
It has to be.
And so what you get is-- well,
that's what they have there,
n lambda, some multiple
of the wavelength,
equals 2d sine theta,
where theta is the incident
angle of that X-ray.
So this is incident--
just to be clear--
incident X-ray.
And these are reflected X-rays.
Now to keep it
simple in this class,
we're just going to say n
equals 1 for 3.091, just
to keep things simple,
because I want to grasp
the basic concepts here.
We're not using X-rays to
get the structure of DNA.
But we're going to use X-rays
to figure out cubic crystal
structures.
I'm going to show
how that works.
So this must be true for--
so this is in parentheses--
for constructive interference.
Those dots that
you saw interface--
interface, no
interference, interference.
This is true for
constructive interference.
Of course, you could write
any equation you want.
But if you want them to be
constructively interfering
when they come out,
that has to be true.
And that's what the Braggs said.
But we're not there yet
right, because now we've
got to do experiments.
So we've got to do experiments.
So what does this mean?
Well, OK, I'm going to
take X-rays of some lambda.
And I'm going to shine
them on a sample.
And I'm going to measure.
So what I'm going to do--
well, I think I have a picture--
I'm going to measure--
there it is.
This is what an X-ray
diffraction experiment
looks like.
So I've got some sample.
And I shine x-rays.
I've got a source of x-rays.
We now know how to
make that source.
And we'll just filter
out one of these lines.
So I've got that source,
and I can change the angle.
And then I've got a detector.
And I can measure did I
get interference or not?
It's just like the dots.
So now, we know that if I
do that and I say I scan--
so I've got intensity.
And now I'm plotting
it with angle.
So now I'm moving the angle
around and I'm changing it.
And, bam, I get interference.
And I see a spot in my detector.
So literally it
would look like this.
You would get some angle
where there's interference.
And the detector would say
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
I see a lot of
x-rays coming off.
And now you change the
angle a few degrees
and I don't see anything,
because it's all
destructive from
these crystal planes.
So it seems like then if I just
vary theta, am I there yet?
The problem is that
I might not know d.
A, ha, but we do know d.
We do know d, because
we learned about d.
For cubic crystals, we know d.
Because for cubic
systems, we know
that d of hkl of any plane, the
distance between those planes
is equal to a over the
square root of h squared
plus k squared plus l squared.
And that's something
that we learned.
This is distance between
Miller planes in cubic crystal.
I'm saving time.
I wrote xtal.
I saved a lot of
time, which I just
wasted by being so proud of it.
I know d.
Well, OK, so what
does that mean?
Well, let's take a
look, because now I'm
going to go back my equation.
And I'm going to say,
OK, lambda equals 2d--
and I'm saying n equals 1.
And I'm not going
to be very specific.
This is now a d that comes
from the spacing between planes
that are specified
by the Miller indices
times the sine of theta.
And I'm putting hkl on the theta
as well, and you'll see why.
Because here's the thing,
now I've got constants.
Now I've got constants,
because look,
this is fixed by the source.
So this is a constant.
If I have copper, then
it's 1.54 Angstroms.
This is a constant.
This is fixed by the crystal.
That's also a constant.
Fixed by the crystal,
because that's also
a constants, because it's
the lattice constant.
We're not changing that.
So for a given set of
planes that these waves
are bouncing off of and maybe
constructively interfering
with, that depending
on the theta,
then these are constants.
So if I regroup then-- so
I'm going to regroup them.
And so I'm going to say that--
let's see, d-- so I'm going to
substitute in that expression
up there down here.
And I'm going to
use a copper source.
So I'm going to say-- well,
let me go through this one step
at a time.
So d equals 1.54
Angstroms over--
let's see-- 2 sine theta hkl.
Now what have I done here?
This is for a copper source.
So I'm fixing in the constant.
So that's the Bragg condition.
But I also know
that d is equal to--
I don't want to write it again.
It's also equal to that.
OK, good.
OK, so let's put that together.
We'll do a little division.
And what we get is 1.54
Angstroms over 2a squared,
the whole thing squared.
I'm squaring it-- I don't
want the square root--
equals sine squared
theta hkl over h
squared plus k squared
plus l squared for--
let's be very specific-- for
constructive interference
and a copper source.
So now, I'm getting
specific because this
is how experiments with
X-ray diffraction are done.
But now the last time
I checked, if you
got something equal
to a constant,
then that something
also is a constant.
And this is a constant.
And so what I need to
do now is figure out I'm
going to measure these data
is where I get a signal.
Remember, I'm going
to now change theta so
that I see where I get signals.
Now, those thetas
divided by the hkl
that they are bouncing
off of must be a constant.
They must not change.
That is at the heart
of X-ray diffraction.
That is at the heart of it.
And so we're going to do
that with a specific example
today and Friday.
But before we do that,
there's another thing
that we can observe.
There's another thing
Oh, this is what
it would look like.
So here it is.
So now I I've changed--
now, why do we do 2 theta?
It's kind of historical.
You plot X-ray
diffraction spectra.
So this is an XRD, X-ray
diffraction spectrum.
This is the intensity
of the peaks.
And these are the peaks.
This is a beautiful thing.
I'm seeing a crystal here.
I'm seeing a crystal.
And by Friday, you will
be seeing a crystal.
Those aren't just peaks.
Those are planes in a crystal.
Those are planes in a
crystal, which tells me
not only that I
have these planes,
but it tells me
what crystal I have.
But that's not how we start.
The way we start is we
do these measurements
and we just read off angles.
So we got to get from there to
there, to crystal structure.
So what I want to determine
is the crystal structure
and the lattice constant.
That's my goal.
What I have is a
spectrum that looks
like this where
all I've done here
is put these
specific angles here.
And you have to be given--
so this is the
aluminum XRD spectrum.
So if you shine
X-rays on aluminum,
this is what you
get if you know also
that those X-rays are
from copper, which
means that lambda is fixed.
So this should be like the
information you get to start.
You'd be given this
spectrum, given these peaks.
And you've be giving
this information here.
It's a copper target.
And from that, we can
determine the crystal structure
in the lattice constant.
Now, there's something--
oh, why do we do 2 theta?
Well, it's historical.
It could have been theta to
make all those dividing by 2s
go away.
But instead, you can see
that as I rotate this,
this changes by theta.
The detector changes by 2 theta.
So that's why extra spectra
are given in 2 theta.
There's no other real
good reason for it,
even though in the Bragg
condition, it's not 2 theta,
it's theta.
This comes from
geometry of the planes.
And this just comes
from historical setups
and how you move the detector.
So what's measured and
plotted is the 2 theta.
But before we go, before
we do this transformation,
where we take an X-ray
spectrum like this
and we get the information we
want, there's one more thing.
And that is not all
reflections are allowed.
Not all reflections are allowed.
And so let's talk about
that, and then we'll
come back to the spectrum.
Now, you can kind
of understand this
by looking at just a simple
kind of comparison here.
So these are the hkl's.
Remember, that's the
hkl for a Miller plane.
This is h squared plus k
squared plus l squared.
Why do we put that?
Because we know we're
going to need it.
There it is right there.
So we know we're
going to need it.
But if you look at the simple
cubic, that's simple cubic.
Any combination of hkl is OK.
There is no combination that
would give you interference
along those plains stacking.
You may say, well, OK, yeah,
what are you talking about?
Why are you even
bringing this up?
Well, when you see the
other two crystal structures
you'll see what I mean.
So now we have the case of BCC--
when you see this,
you see BCC and FCC.
And what I'm showing you
here isn't the 100 plane.
It's the 200 plane.
So this is the family--
remember, the family--
of 200 planes.
There they are.
But now you see
that what happens--
and I have a picture
here to show you,
but I'll tell you first--
what happens is
the light comes in.
So there's those
squiggly X-rays.
It comes in.
And there is, OK,
d, which depends
on the lattice
constant, is related
to the lattice constant.
But look.
Now there's another
plane in between.
There's another
And in fact, with
the 200 planes,
that plane in between
exactly cancels out
the constructive interference.
Here it is.
So there's what
I would have had.
If you want to think about this
as the 100, there's the 200s.
But notice when I go from 100 to
200s, I add this plane in here.
And because that
plane has atoms in it,
because that plane has atoms
in it, it acts like a mirror,
and it can also reflect.
And so what happens is I would
have had this nice-- there
it is.
There's a picture I drew.
There's that first
X-ray bouncing off.
There's the second
one bouncing off.
And those are nicely in phase.
So I would see that.
If that's the angle
that gave that to me,
I'd see that in the detector.
But now, for BCC or FCC, I've
got something in the middle.
And that something in the
middle is exactly canceling out.
You see that?
So now, it cancels that out.
In fact, that's
called forbidden.
You won't see a signal.
And so these are
called selection rules.
And for a simple cubic, you
can see there's nothing inside.
So there's nothing in this
unit cell that could do this.
So everything's allowed.
Whether there's a plane in
there or not, it doesn't matter.
The selection rule is
whether it's ever allowed.
And for a simple
cubic, everything's
fine, because nothing
would cancel out.
But in here, you see
in this 200 case,
you can see very clearly
from that picture
how it cancels out.
But there's many other
kinds of angles or planes
that might also do that.
And so I'm going
to just give you
what the selection rules are.
We won't go through
and derive them all.
But let's see, they are
actually quite simple.
And so I'm going
to write them down.
So if we look at
allowed reflections,
and then we look at
forbidden reflections--
so this is what the
selection rules tell us--
so if it's simple cubic,
then it's any h, k, and l.
And there's no
forbidden reflections.
But if we go through BCC
and FCC, then what we find
is that for BCC
the selection rule
is that h plus k
plus l equals even.
If that is even-- and
we won't derive these,
but it comes from the
same very simple picture
I just showed you.
If something is in there
that can cancel out
the constructive interference,
it's going to be forbidden.
Otherwise, it can
constructively interfere.
And that's what this tells us.
For BCC, it turns out
to be h plus k plus l.
And so here, what's
forbidden for BCC
is h plus k plus l is odd.
And for FCC it's h, k,
l, all odd or all even.
And the forbidden FCC is
h, k, l, mixed odd/even.
These are the selection rules.
So if I were to give you the
planes that you see, then
right away from
an X-ray spectrum,
you could just use
these selection rules
right away to know something,
to know something about it.
And if you work this
out and you look at,
OK, so we have simple cubic.
So h squared plus k squared
plus 1, 100, BCC, FCC, you're
not going to see it.
That doesn't mean that there is
no 100 plane in those crystals.
It just means that if
you shine X-rays on it,
you will not see it.
OK, so the 110,
though, now here, OK,
so we see our-- by the way,
mixed, even, odd, and it
adds to odd.
That's why neither
one of these works.
Here we go, adds
to even, BCC OK,
but it's still mixed
even odd, won't be FCC.
3, it's not mixed, so it can
be a allowable reflection
for FCC, but not for BBC.
Because if you add
them up, it's on odd,
and so forth and so forth.
And look it, 7 doesn't exist,
because you can't do it.
No matter how hard you
try, you can't get 7.
That's OK.
And there's 8 and
9 and so forth.
So 9 also-- so
here it's allowed,
but it's not allowed
in either of these,
because you can't get either
of these to be satisfied.
This is what selection
rules give us.
And it comes,
again, from simple--
oh, OK, well, that
that's another thing.
I said a simple, I have
to tell you something,
because the Bragg condition,
it relies on an assumption
that's mostly true.
But the Bragg condition
requires that the reflection
is independent--
some of you may be thinking
I did I draw it onto the atom
or did I draw it
in between atoms?
Where did that thing--
does it have to
reflect off an atom?
We're not going there.
With the Bragg condition,
it's independent of the atom
positions in a plane.
And the second
thing which is what
I've been sort of alluding
to is that the atomic planes
are mirror like.
I mean, this is sort of
an obvious assumption
since I've been assuming
they've been mirrors.
But if you start thinking
about atom position,
you might go back to that
selection rule picture
and say, well, wait
a second, does it
always have to hit the atom?
What if this one was over
or something like that?
No, no, we assume it's
just one continuous plane
if there are atoms in it.
If there's no atom in it, then
it's not a reflective plane.
But it's continuous in the
assumption of the Bragg
condition.
Now we go back to our picture.
So what we want to do
is, again, our goal,
should we choose, our goal is
to go from this spectrum knowing
this information--
it's a copper target and being
able to read off the peak--
our goal is to determine
the crystal structure
and the lattice constant.
That's our goal.
And let me let me
just write this again,
because it's
extremely important.
So maybe I'll keep that one.
I'm going to erase this and
put it right in the middle,
because this is what drives XRD.
This is what drives
XRD, which is
that our goal is figure out
what makes this constant always.
Now, you say what is
this constant always?
This is the expression, which
I'm going to write again.
So what I have if
it's a copper source
is 1.54 Angstroms
divided by 2 a squared.
That's a constant.
That equals sine squared of the
theta for some plane divided
by h squared plus k
squared plus l squared.
So I'm just kind of
repeating what I've said
and what I've written elsewhere,
but that is really it.
That is what we do
in X-ray diffraction.
What makes this?
Well, by this what I mean
is this term on the right.
How do I make sure that this
never changes its value?
Because the thing on the
left never changes its value.
And just making sure that
you've got that concept,
that is this, oh, yeah.
And it turns out I got a recipe
for you to follow to do this.
And it's on the previous slide.
And so we'll start
thinking about it now.
And we've got five more minutes.
And then on Friday, we
will finish this and then
talk about what to do with
those continuous X-rays.
So what do I do?
Well, the way you do
this is systematically.
And the first thing
you do is you read off
the 2 theta values that generate
a set of sine squared value.
So that the X-ray
spectrum measures 2 theta.
But you know from here
that I need sine squared.
So I'm going to write down
the sine squared values.
So that's a first step.
So for the first one,
I've got the first peak.
So I would start to log my data.
The first peak and
the 2 theta is 38.43.
And the sine squared theta is--
and I'm just going
to do that math--
0.1083.
OK, good.
And the next one, the
next peak is 44.67.
And the sine square of
that is 0.1444 so on.
So you read off all the peaks
and you make those columns.
So I've gone through.
Now the second one,
normalize the sine
squared theta values
by the smallest value.
You say, so why am I doing that?
Trust me, this will
achieve our goal.
This will get us there.
This is a nice simple
recipe to achieve our goal.
So the next column
would simply be
sine squared theta divided
by sine squared theta min.
Well, I ran out of
room there, but that's
going to be obviously 1.
And this would be
1.333 and so on.
So that's the next one.
So I'm just setting
that the top row to 1.
I'm setting the top row to 1.
Good.
Now, I'm going to
clear fractions.
So I've normalized, and now
I'm going to clear fractions.
And if I do that,
I clear fractions.
Well, you say, what does
clearing fractions mean?
It means just what it implies.
I don't want fractions anymore.
It means I just need to multiply
the whole set of numbers
by something that gets
rid of the fractions.
And it turns out that
in this case it is 3.
So 3 times sine squared theta
over sine squared theta min,
and that is going to be 3.
And that is going
to be 4 and so on.
We're almost there.
And we're not going
to finish today,
but we're getting real close.
That's good.
It leaves us with a sense of
anticipation and excitement.
So, OK, I got clear fractions.
What values of h, k, l,
if I have this h squared
plus k squared plus l
squared, would give me
the sequence of clear fractions?
What values of h squared?
Now, remember, you say,
why am I doing this?
Again, go back to this.
This is why.
I have a simple recipe for
you to accomplish this goal.
That's where we're
going with this.
So I'm now going to see
with those clear fractions,
now it's very easy
to see what h, k,
l's would give me-- h squared
plus k squared plus l squared
equals that clear
fraction value.
So for example, here,
well, if this is h
squared plus k squared plus
l squared, maybe this is 111.
And This might be
200, for example.
So we're almost there.
We're so close.
What we're going
to do is I'm going
to start on Friday I'll
put this up on the board
and we'll finish filling it
out and going from this matrix
to the crystal structure
and the lattice constant.
OK, have a great Halloween.